Uh, the impeachment discussions about Donald
Trump are getting both very concrete and much
less, I guess abstract by, by by definition,
the chairman of the House judiciary is a congress
woman, a congressman Jerry Nadler Naturaler
is now saying that Robert Mueller's report
contains quote, very substantial evidence
that Donald Trump is quote, guilty of high
crimes and misdemeanors.
Now you may know that there's a particular
relevance to that term.
High crimes and misdemeanors are impeachable
offenses.
And this is sort of setting the table for
Robert Mueller's testimony later this week
on Wednesday where Nadler says molar must
be allowed to spell this out in detail in
front of the committee.
If there were to be impeachment hearings,
it would be Nadler's house judiciary committee,
which would lead them.
And there is not agreement among the Democratic
Party about whether they should pursue impeachment
at this point, there are more than 80 Democrats
who called for starting the impeachment inquiry
immediately.
There are some prominent Democrats like speaker
of the house, Nancy Pelosi and Nadler himself
who have been resistant to it.
So the breaking news is not an Adler thinks
there's evidence.
Okay, I want to cut right to sort of like
the core of what's important here.
It's time for the impeachment discussion to
become really specific and narrow.
Okay.
Because it's not good.
It's not healthy, it's not productive that
every time some little thing happens, oh,
now might be the time for impeachment, but
it might not.
And Pelosi says no, and who knows who says
yes?
I've been saying for months now that there
should be an impeachment inquiry that starts
in the house and that should start immediately
or as soon as possible.
That's been my position.
Get the contents of the Mueller report out
in public, make everything in the report known
to as many people as possible.
But Democrats need to make a decision about
this and they need to make that very soon.
Robert Mueller testifies Wednesday.
If the content of the report justifies an
impeachment inquiry, which I believe it does.
Remember the inquiry is just step one in the
entire process.
Then that inquiry should start immediately
after Robert Mueller's testimony.
I happen to believe having read the report
that the contents do justify an impeachment
inquiry.
If it's time to do it, then let's do it.
If the idea and this is a respectable position,
some have the idea that it would be more damaging
to Donald Trump to start the impeachment inquiry
in say six months because the 2020 election
will be more ramped up at that point in time.
There would be more disruption of Trump's
campaign to be done at that time.
When right now it's really just the Democratic
primary that's getting attention.
That's, that's fine.
Let's come to that agreement and let's shut
our mouths about it.
Until that point, the constant back and forth
the Democrats fighting with each other about
impeachment inquiry versus not, it will not
help remove Trump in 2020 the most effective
path forward would be let molar speak on Wednesday,
publicize what he says and allow the truth
of that testimony to foment a deserved outrage
in the United States.
We're going to learn much more very soon about
the Jeffrey Epstein case and it is quite possible
that Donald Trump will be implicated in some
of those documents in some way, shape or form.
Maybe not for the alleged child rape that
Donald Trump was accused of, but possibly
let's get that information out into the open
and allow that to grow the outrage in the
country.
This could easily build for the next five
to seven months and then it could be the perfect
time to start the impeachment inquiry when
it would be most damaging to Donald Trump.
Now, some of you will hear me talking about
this and you'll be outraged.
Concern Trolling David are, are you suggesting
that dems play politics with the timing of
something as serious as impeachment?
Yeah, I am.
That's what I'm doing.
We need to win.
Okay.
The right place.
Politics with the lives of undocumented immigrants
seeking asylum, the right place, politics
with the lives of civilians in Iran as Donald
Trump authorizes and then cancels a strike
on Iran.
They play politics with debt and deficit and
taxes and healthcare.
I'm saying it's okay to play politics with
the timing of the impeachment inquiry plus
or minus a few months.
Yes, that's what I'm saying.
It's time to stop losing if calculating the
timing of an impeachment inquiry in order
to most damage Trump is what we have to do.
It is nothing compared to what they've done,
but Democrats need to decide what the plan
is like now because the worst possible thing
they can do is just continue public infighting
about it for the next six months or 12 months
or all the way to the 2020 election.
That's how Trump wins.
I don't want him to win, so it's time to really
think about it.
Do we want to do it now?
Do we want to do it in six months or not at
all?
And if that's the case, we focused on the
2020 election, but the end fighting's got
to stop and the back and forth has to end
today.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Follow both of us there